masahiro tanako
suffered that concussion on july 4th on
a 112 mile per hour line drive that
giancarlo stanton hit
he was back on a mound two and a half
weeks later in that hat
is a carbon fiber insert andrew
benintendi for the red sox
did not play in last night's game he
swings and misses as the bottom falls
out tanaka starts his day with a
strikeout
kevin fellar stands in he smacks a
ground ball right side
long way to go for the mayhew and it
scoops through for a one-out single
and the red sox have their first base
runner here in the top of the first
devers seven for 15 in his career
against the right-hander tanaka
fastball is fouled into the glove for
strike three second k for tanaka
two gone in the first inning and the
hitter is the shortstop xander bogarts
tanaka deals fly ball to deep right back
to the track goes judge he's got it
measured and makes the catch on the
warning track
for the third hour zach godly to make
his first red sox
start and it's at yankee stadium you'll
see dj lemay hugh aaron judge and gleber
torres in the bottom of the first up
that's a chopper left side and a third
deborah circles around it
throws the mayhem up comes aaron judge
the judge
has now homered in three straight games
he has done that
on five different occasions but has yet
to hit home runs
in four straight games and we'll keep an
eye on that tonight
that ball is drilled and aaron judge
for the fourth consecutive game launches
a home run
for the first time in his career he's
homered in four straight games
and you can't be any hotter right now
than aaron judge
he's guilty of putting the yankees in
the lead
one to nothing oh what a shot from aaron
judge
so first and second nobody out here's
gary sanchez is old for 15.
start the season gary sanchez with his
first hit of the season
a basic to right that'll load the bases
oh he's got to feel good about that
he says get the ball and so another
bind for godly and the red sox base has
loaded nobody out for geo or shella
geo list one to center deep bradley back
on the track
that one's gone that's a great
slam home run for geo shella
adios the yankees
are now up five to nothing the red sox
nightmare continues
in the bronx the red sox have run is it
first and second
and if he can get through this inning
probably won't see him again that'll
bring up zander bogart's
trying to get the red sox on the board
here xander swings drives one of the air
to right center field toward the gap way
back by the bullpen
off the top of the bullpen gate here
comes benny to score
and the throw to second it gets away and
belatedly pilar comes home and he scores
two runs for the red sox and they're
back in it now now 5-2
that will also end the day for masahiro
tanaka in his first game of the season
so the eggs have the bases loaded
all courtesy of the walk and gleber
torres gets a shot here
and a curve is popped up in the center
field jackie moving back a step or two
he's there
and he makes the catch and the yankees
leave him loaded
so the red sox stay within striking
distance 24 year old nick
nelson about to make his major league
debut in a yankees red sox game
delivers 0-2 and starts his career with
a strikeout on three pitches with
fastballs that go 96-97-98
it's bogarts to lead off this sixth
inning for boston they trail 5-2
that is pinpoint to get one of the top
hitters in the league
everything about what he's doing tonight
impressive swinging
i miss nolan goes downswing so
nick nelson strikes out bogarts and
more about this seventh inning against
nick nelson who's making his major
league debut
and has thrown a pair of scoreless
innings so far swinging
a miss he gets lynn this is just a
filthy change
it doesn't seem like there's any nerves
he's very composed out there four
strikeouts
for nick nelson ben and he rolls one to
the right side lemay you gets to it
fields it throws you know and there we
go the bosox in the seventh
they leave one david hale who has two
saves in his career that's all trying to
go the final six outs in this one and
vasquez swings and misses he tried to
hold up he couldn't
breaking pitch from hale so vasquez
strikes on
hale's first punch out with one out
here's alex verdugo down goes for dugo
he pulled the string on him
so david hale is making me shut my mouth
about who pitches the ninth inning
lo and behold here the red sox are going
to bring the tying run to the plate
with two outs and it's been intended you
would think
that you'd have your lefty closer zach
britton ready for this situation but
there's no sign of that clinging and a
miss in the ball game is over
so it doesn't matter who was in and new
york is a major league best 6-1 to open
20-20